patience in Brussels is wearing thin the
EU is looking to London for a clear
indication of what it wants to do and if
London can't agree then the consequences
are clear as it stands today a No Deal
bricks it is likely we are ready for it
even if it isn't what I want the German
Chancellor Angela Merkel has said the
future of the European Union is more
important than brexit and I agree with
her in London a potentially important
shift teresa may say she wants another
extension to the brexit deadline and
will seek political consensus to break
months of parliamentary deadlock I'm
offering to sit down with the leader of
the opposition and to try to agree a
plan that we would both stick to to
ensure that we leave the European Union
and that we do so with a deal the
initial reaction from the Labour Party
leader Jeremy Corbyn positive but
cautious of course I'm very happy to
meet her we need to have a discussion
with the Prime Minister we need to
ensure that Parliament has an
opportunity to vote on proposals that
prevent is crashing out of the EU in the
at the end of next week in Paris another
reminder from Europe of the need for
Britain to decide soon
the French president underlining that
British interests aren't the only ones
that count not our priority must be the
proper functioning of a European Union
and the single market for you shouldn't
be held hostage to a political crisis
every 90 Kingdom on a long-term basis
the EU will have to agree any extension
to the brexit date France is not the
only sceptical voice let's go straight
to London and our correspondent bigoted
MA standing by for us beer get a lot of
developments today will the Prime
Minister be able to get the support
she's not received so far from her own
party from the opposition from Labour
well the initial sounds that we've had
from Labour are very positive they
see it as a genuine offer as the at
least this is what they say they also
have to present themselves as open they
have time and again
hasta resume to sit down together and to
come to some compromise and have been
very critical that she hasn't done it
much earlier we know that in her own
party there is a lot of resistance
especially from the right of her own
party one of the conservative members of
the right wing of the party has said
well she's now handing brexit over to
make it deal with a socialist so really
not very happy and they are saying that
they are fighting tooth and nail to
prevent something like a softer brexit
like a customs union which is something
that labor would like to see so really
it's about the shape of brexit what form
of praxis that's really the issue and
it's about the guarantees that Teresa
may can also give to labor what is she
going to how is she going to go through
it go about it she hasn't flashed this
out so the next day's really will be
really crucial for these talks okay this
is a major shift of moving over and
looking across the aisle for support
what happens if the Prime Minister fails
to get labour on board well that's the
million dollar question what we know is
that on the 12th of April the UK will
leave the European Union without any
deal without any provision for the
future which would have dire
consequences for business business are
very afraid of of this Northern Ireland
business in particular they are so
dependent on the European Union for for
all their trade so this is something
that Theresa May says she wants to virt
this is why she goes over to labour it's
also said something that most
parliamentarians are trying in a
parallel process also to block but we
know if there is no deal in London a
further withdrawal agreement isn't sign
if there isn't another extension with
the European Union then this will be the
this will be what's going to happen and
just over a week's time okay that is a
big cudgel she has the April 12th
deadline looming let's assume that
Theresa May manages to get labour on
board when could we see Parliament
voting
well there really isn't that much time
if she wants to look for another
extension and I presume that it hooks
also with labor have to take some time
she has to really get this off the
ground and the next days because there
is another summit in Brussels about a
possible extension and Brussels will
need to know by the beginning of next
week
so really in the next stage she has to
see some results for this new approach
to brexit bigamous for us bringing us up
today from London
thank you very much